de la forêt la plus grande et la plus préservée au monde,
la forêt boréale du Canada.
Elle s'étend sur tout la largeur nord du Canada, dans l’État du Labrador,
et elle héberge le dernier grand troupeau de caribous sauvages
au monde, le troupeau de la rivière Georges,
qui compte approximativement 400 000 animaux.
Malheureusement, quand je suis allé là-bas, je n'en ai vu aucun,
mais les bois feront office de preuves.
Dans toute la forêt boréale, nous avons la chance d'avoir
une abondance incroyable de zones humides.
Les zones humides sont partout dans le monde un des écosystèmes les plus menacés.
Ce sont des écosystèmes essentiels,
ils filtrent l'air, l'eau,
ils emprisonnent de grandes quantités de gaz à effet de serre,
et ils abritent une faune très diversifiée.
Dans la forêt boréale, ces zones sont aussi l'endroit où
presque 50% des 800 des espèces d'oiseaux
que l'on trouve en Amérique du Nord migrent pour nourrir et élever leur progéniture.
Dans l'état de l'Ontario, la forêt boréale s'étend au Sud
jusqu'à la côte Nord du lac Supérieur.
Ces forêt boréales d'une incroyable beauté
ont été source d'inspiration pour certaines des plus célèbres œuvres d'art
de l'histoire canadienne, le Groupe de Sept fut très inspiré
par ces paysages,
par conséquent, cette forêt n'est pas seulement un élément clef de
notre héritage naturel,
mais aussi une importante part de notre héritage culturel.
A Manitoba, voici une photo de la rive orientale du Lac Winnipeg ;
c'est un site nouvellement inscrit
au Patrimoine Culturel de l'UNESCO.
Au Saskatchewan, tout comme dans toute la forêt,
qui abrite quelques-unes des plus célèbres rivières,
un réseau incroyable de rivières et de lacs
dont tout élève entend parler en classe,
la Rivière de la Paix, l'Athabasca, la Rivière Churchill, ici, la Mackenzie,
ces réseaux étaient historiquement des routes
pour les voyageurs et les coureurs des bois,
les premiers explorateurs non-aborigènes du Grand Nord canadien
qui, s'inspirant des Premières Nations,
ont voyagé en canoë pour partir à la recherche
d'une route commerciale, un passage du Nord-Ouest pour le commerce de la fourrure.
Dans le Nord, la forêt boréale est bordée par la toundra,
et juste en dessous, dans le Yukon,
il y a cette magnifique vallée, la vallée Tombstone.
La vallée Tombstone abrite le troupeau des caribous Porc-Épic.
Vous en avez certainement entendu parler,
parce qu'ils élèvent leurs petits
dans le Refuge National Arctique de la Vie Sauvage.
Eh bien, leur lieu d'hibernation est aussi menacé
et n'est pas non plus protégé,
et pourrait être potentiellement exploité
pour ses ressources en gaz et minéraux.
La frontière ouest de la forêt boréale en Colombie britannique
est marquée par la présence des Coast Mountains ;
de l'autre côté de ces montagnes
se trouve la plus grande forêt tropicale tempérée qui existe encore au monde,
la forêt du Grand ours,
nous en reparlerons plus en détails dans quelques minutes.
La forêt boréale abrite une énorme variété
de peuplades indigènes
et une culture riche et diversifiée.
Je crois qu'une des raisons
pour lesquelles tant de ces groupes ont conservé un lien avec le passé,
pratiquent encore leurs langues originelles,
les chants, les danses, les traditions,
je crois qu'une explication est l'isolement,
l'étendue et l'aspect sauvage
de cet écosystème presque intact à 95%.
Je pense que tout particulièrement maintenant,
alors que nous traversons une crise environnementale,
nous avons beaucoup à apprendre de ces gens
qui ont vécu en harmonie avec cet écosystème
depuis plus de 10 000 ans.
Au cœur de cet écosystème, nous trouvons l'exact opposé
de toutes ces valeurs que nous avons évoquées,
et je crois que ce sont des valeurs essentielles
qui nous rendent fiers d'être Canadiens.
Voici les sables bitumineux de l'Alberta,
la plus grande réserve de pétrole de la planète
en dehors de l'Arabie Saoudite.
Emprisonnées sous la forêt boréale
et les zones humides du nord de l'Alberta
nous trouvons ces vastes réserves de bitume collant et goudronneux.
L'exploitation minière de cette ressource
entraîne une dévastation à une échelle jamais observée jusqu'à présent.
Je voudrais vous donner un ordre d'idée de l'ampleur de ce phénomène.
Regardez ce camion, là,
c'est le plus gros camion de ce type au monde.
C'est un camion-benne de 400 tonnes
et il fait 15 m de long
sur 10 m de large, et 8 m de haut.
Si je me tenais à côté de ce camion,
ma tête ne dépasserait pas le bas
de la partie jaune de l'enjoliveur.
Dans l'espace occupé par ce camion,
vous pourriez construire une maison à 2 étages, de 300 m²,
facilement. J'ai fait le calcul.
Au lieu de le voir comme un camion,
voyez ceci comme une maison de 300 m².
C'est déjà une belle maison.
Alignez ces camions/maisons les uns à la suite des autres
ici, du bas
jusqu'en haut.
Ensuite, voyez combien cette petite partie d'une seule mine paraît gigantesque.
Maintenant vous pouvez appliquer le même raisonnement
ici.
Vous voyez, -- bien sûr, si vous continuez,
ces camions deviennent aussi petits qu'un pixel.
Une nouvelle fois, imaginez-les ici.
Quelle taille fait cette portion de la mine ?
Cela représenterait une très grande zone urbaine,
probablement plus grande que la ville de Victoria.
Et c'est une mine, parmi tant d'autres,
10 pour le moment.
C'est une partie d'une exploitation minière,
et 40 ou 50 autres sont en train d'être approuvées.
Aucun projet de mine de sables bitumineux n'a pour l'instant été refusé,
c'est juste un coup de tampon.
L'autre méthode d'extraction est appelée l'in-situ.
Là, d'énormes quantités d'eau
sont surchauffées et injectées dans le sol,
grâce à ces vastes réseaux de tuyaux,
lignes sismiques, forages, stations de compression.
Même si cela paraît moins répugnant
que les mines, cela fait encore plus de dégâts.
Cette méthode a des conséquences sur une grande partie de la nature
où nous constatons une réduction de 90% des espèces clefs,
comme le caribou forestier et le grizzli,
cela consomme encore plus d'énergie, plus d'eau,
et produit au moins autant de gaz à effet de serre.
Par conséquent ces exploitations in-situ sont au moins
aussi dramatiques pour l'écosystème que les mines.
Le pétrole issu de ces deux méthodes
produit plus de gaz à effet de serre que n'importe quel autre pétrole.
C'est l'une des raisons qui fait qu'on l'appelle
le pétrole le plus sale du monde.
C'est aussi une des raisons pour lesquelles
c'est la plus grande source de CO2 au Canada et
celle qui augmente le plus.
C'est aussi pour cette raison que le Canada est maintenant le numéro 3
en termes de production de CO2 par personne.
Les bassins de décantation sont les retenues d'eau les plus toxiques de la planète.
Les sables pétrolifères -- ou devrais-je dire les sables bitumineux --
"sables pétrolifères" est un terme créé par les services de relations publiques
pour que les compagnies pétrolières ne promeuvent pas
quelque chose qui évoque une substance gluante et goudronneuse,
ce qu'est le pétrole le plus sale du monde.
D'où leur décision d'appeler ça des sables pétrolifères.
Les sables bitumineux consomment plus d'eau que n'importe quel autre procédé de distillation,
3 à 5 barils d'eau sont utilisés, pollués
et ensuite reversés dans des bassins de décantation,
les retenues d'eau les plus toxiques au monde.
SemCrude, un exploitant parmi d'autres,
dans un seul de ces bassins,
rejette quotidiennement 250 000 tonnes de cette crasse toxique.
Cela crée les dépôts les plus toxiques
de l'histoire de la planète.
Jusqu'à maintenant, ils ont produit assez de toxines
pour couvrir la surface du Lac Érié sur 30 cm d'épaisseur.
Les bassins de décantation couvrent une surface de 36 km².
Cela représente les deux tiers de l'île de Manhattan.
De Wall Street jusqu'à l'extrémité sud de Manhattan,
jusqu'à la 120ème rue.
C'est une absolue...
Voici un des plus vastes bassins.
Cela représenterait... Je ne sais pas, la moitié de Manhattan.
Vous pouvez le remettre dans son contexte,
c'est uniquement une partie relativement restreinte
d'un des 10 complexes miniers, avec 40 ou 50 de plus
à venir bientôt.
Bien sûr, ces bassins de décantation,--
eh bien, on ne peut pas en voir beaucoup depuis l'espace,
mais on peut voir ceux-là, peut-être devrions-nous arrêter de les appeler bassins --
ces immenses zones humides toxiques sont construites
sans revêtement sur les rives de la rivière Athabasca.
Le cours de la rivière Athabasca
mène à plusieurs communautés aborigènes.
Les 800 personnes qui vivent à Fort Chippewa
retrouvent les toxines dans la chaîne alimentaire,
cela a été scientifiquement prouvé.
Les toxines des sables bitumineux se retrouvent dans la chaîne alimentaire,
et cela génère des taux de cancer
plus de 10 fois supérieurs que dans le reste du Canada.
Malgré cela, les gens doivent vivre,
doivent manger cette nourriture pour survivre.
Le surcoût
de l'envoi par avion dans ces communautés aborigènes reculées
et le taux élevé de chômage
font de cette nourriture une absolue nécessité pour leur survie.
Il n'y a pas si longtemps, un descendant des Premières Nations m'a prêté un bateau.
Il m'a dit : "Quand tu seras sur la rivière,
ne mange de poisson sous aucun prétexte.
C'est cancérigène."
Et pourtant, sous le porche de la maison de cette homme,
j'ai vu 4 poissons. Il devait nourrir sa famille pour survivre.
En tant que parent, je ne peux pas imaginer ce que l'on ressent.
Et c'est ce que nous faisons.
La forêt boréale est aussi peut-être
notre meilleur atout contre le réchauffement et le changement du climat.
La forêt boréale retient plus de CO2
qu'aucun autre écosystème terrestre.
C'est absolument crucial.
Nous sommes en train
de détruire le plus dense réservoir de gaz à effet de serre,
deux fois plus de gaz est emprisonné dans
la forêt boréale par m² que dans les forêts tropicales.
Ce que nous faisons, c'est détruire
ce réservoir de CO2 pour en faire une bombe au CO2.
Nous remplaçons cela avec le plus grand
projet industriel de l'histoire de l'Humanité,
qui produit le pétrole dont la fabrication requiert
le gaz à effet de serre le plus concentré en carbone au monde.
Et nous faisons tout ceci dans la seconde plus grande
réserve de pétrole de la planète.
C'est une des raisons pour lesquelles le Canada,
historiquement un héros contre le changement climatique --
nous étions un des premiers signataires des accords de Kyoto.
Maintenant, nous sommes le pays qui a des lobbyistes à plein-temps
en Union Européenne et à Washington,
menaçant de déclencher une guerre commerciale si ces pays
envisagent de mettre en place une législation positive
pour limiter l'import de pétroles chargés en carbone,
de gaz à effet de serre, ou tout autre du même type,
dans les conférences internationales,
qu'elles soient à Copenhague ou à Cancun,
les conférences internationales sur le changement climatique,
nous sommes le pays qui reçoit chaque jour le "prix du dinosaure",
désignant la plus grande entrave
au progrès sur ce sujet.
Juste 100 km en aval
se trouve le plus grand delta d'eau douce,
le delta Paix-Athabasca,
le seul à la jonction des 4 routes migratoires.
C'est une zone humide très importante,
peut-être la plus importante sur cette planète.
Un habitat incroyable pour la moitié des espèces d'oiseaux
que l'on peut trouver en Amérique du Nord, qui migrent ici.
Et aussi le dernier refuge pour le plus grand troupeau de bisons sauvages,
et aussi, bien sûr, l'habitat essentiel pour tout un tas d'autres espèces.
Mais ceci est également menacé par l'importante quantité
d'eau pompée dans l'Athabasca,
qui alimente ces zones humides,
et par l'incroyable poids toxique
de la plus grande retenue d'eau toxique non protégée sur la planète
qui se répand dans la chaîne alimentaire
pour toutes les espèces en aval.
Aussi mauvaise que soit la situation, les choses ne vont aller
qu'en se dégradant, et énormément.
Voici l'infrastructure d'aujourd'hui.
Voici ce qui prévu pour 2015.
Vous voyez ici l'oléoduc Keystone
qui charriera les sables bitumineux jusqu'au golfe du Mexique,
forçant le passage d'un oléoduc dans le cœur,
le cœur agricole de l'Amérique du Nord, des États-Unis,
et scellant ainsi le contrat avec le pétrole le plus sale du monde
avec l'accord des États-Unis,
décourageant aussi fortement
le futur des énergies propres aux USA.
Voici la route qui descend de la vallée Mackenzie.
Un oléoduc sera installé pour récolter les gaz naturels
de la mer de Beaufort jusqu'au cœur
du 3ème plus grand bassin versant au monde,
le seul encore intact à 95%.
Construire un oléoduc avec une autoroute industrielle
modifierait pour toujours cette incroyable zone sauvage,
vraie rareté sur la planète de nos jours.
La forêt tropicale du Grand Ours est juste derrière
cette colline, là, et, en quelques kilomètres, nous passons de ces
forêts boréales sèches aux arbres centenaires,
d'environ 25 cm de diamètre,
à la forêt tempérée le long de la côte,
balayée par les pluies, aux arbres millénaires,
6 m de diamètre, un écosystème complétement différent.
La forêt du Grand Ours est généralement considérée
comme le plus important écosystème de forêt tempérée côtière
au monde.
On y trouve les plus importantes densités,
certaines des plus emblématiques espèces, des plus menacées également,
et pourtant, il existe une proposition, bien évidemment, de construire un oléoduc
pour y installer des pétroliers, 10 fois la taille de l'Exxon Valdez,
au beau milieu des eaux les plus difficilement navigables au monde,
alors qu'il y a seulement quelques années,
un ferry de la BC y a fait naufrage.
Quand un des ces pétroliers charriant des sables bitumineux,
charriant le pétrole le plus sale, 10 fois plus gros que l'Exxon Valdez,
heurtera finalement un rocher, et sombrera,
nous serons face à un des pires désastres écologiques
que cette planète aura jamais vu.
Voici les plans pour 2030.
Ils proposent une multiplication par 4 de la production,
ce qui forcerait à industrialiser une zone de la taille de la Floride.
En faisant cela, nous supprimerions
une grande part de notre plus grand puits de CO2
pour le remplacer par le pétrole générant
la plus grande émission de gaz à effet de serre.
Le monde n'a pas besoin de nouvelles mines de goudron.
Le monde n'a pas besoin de plus d'oléoducs
pour renforcer notre addiction aux énergies fossiles.
Et le monde n'a certainement pas besoin
que les plus grandes retenues d'eau toxiques grossissent encore et se multiplient,
menaçant encore plus les communautés vivant en aval.
Reconnaissons-le, nous vivons tous en aval
en cette époque de réchauffement global et de changement climatique.
Ce dont nous avons besoin, c'est d'agir
pour s'assurer que le Canada respecte
les quantités d'eau douce
dont nous disposons dans ce pays.
Nous devons nous assurer que ces zones humides et ces forêts,
la meilleure, la plus importante et la plus essentielle
défense contre le réchauffement de la planète, soient protégées,
assurons-nous que nous ne relâcherons pas cette bombe de CO2 dans l'atmosphère.
Nous devons tous nous rassembler
et dire non aux sables bitumineux.
Nous pouvons le faire. Il existe un réseau important
à travers le monde qui se bat pour arrêter ce projet.
Je pense simplement que ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui doit se décider uniquement au Canada.
Tout le monde dans cette pièce, tout le monde au Canada,
tous ceux écoutant cette conférence ont un rôle à jouer
et, je pense, une responsabilité.
Parce que ce que nous faisons ici
changera notre histoire,
cela rendra réelles nos chances de survie,
et les chances de nos enfants de survivre
et d'avoir un avenir riche.
Nous disposons d'un don incroyable en la forêt boréale,
une opportunité sans pareil de préserver
notre meilleur atout contre le réchauffement climatique,
mais nous pourrions passer à côté.
Les sables bitumineux pourraient menacer
pas seulement une section de la forêt.
Cela remet en question la vie et la santé
de certains des peuples les plus vulnérables et les moins privilégiés,
les communautés aborigènes qui ont tant à nous apprendre.
Cela pourrait détruire le delta d'Athabasca,
le plus grand et peut-être le plus beau delta de la planète.
Cela pourrait détruire la forêt du Grand Ours,
la plus grande forêt tempérée au monde.
Cela pourrait avoir un impact majeur
sur l'avenir du cœur agricole de l'Amérique du Nord.
J'espère que tous, si vous avez été émus par cette conférence,
rejoindrez la communauté internationale grandissante
pour forcer le Canada à prendre ses responsabilités,
pour convaincre le Canada de revenir à son statut de champion du changement climatique
au lieu d'être le méchant de l'histoire,
et à dire non aux sables bitumineux
et oui à un avenir fait d'énergies propres pour tous.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)